[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas en france
24 el programa en el que analizamos la
actualidad de la eurocopa de naciones y
la copa américa
estos son los titulares
lancia volvió a ganar a alemania en una
gran cita internacional los galos
vencieron por la mínima a los germanos
en su debut en la euro que reivindicaron
su papel de favoritos al torneo vamos a
analizar la primera fecha del denominado
grupo de la muerte
se abre la segunda fecha de la fase de
grupos de la eurocopa italia de
civilidad suiza en roma en el duelo
estelar de la jornada cat se requiere
otra victoria para certificar que está
aquí para ganar el título
brasil y colombia buscarán este jueves
su segunda victoria en la copa américa
ante perú y venezuela- hacemos la previa
de esta segunda fecha la canarinha y los
cafeteros tienen la mirada puesta en
caminar el pase los cuartos de final
gracias por estar con nosotros vamos a
empezar hablando de la selección
francesa y para ello un día más tenemos
el placer de contar con la presencia de
sara castro director ya del diario 'as'
hola juan un gusto estar con ustedes
como siempre les digo creo que hemos
visto muy buen fútbol en esta eurocopa
entonces arranquemos a analizar así es
directora del diario 'as' co lombia ayer
martes se abre el grupo efe grupo de la
muerte y portugal le ganó a hungría por
3 a 0 mientras que francia se impuso
alemania por 1 a 0 con un gol en propia
puerta de hummers los lusos y los galos
lideran el grupo precia ganó alemán en
el mundial de rusia 2018 y ahora vuelve
a ganarle en una máxima cita
internacional ya no es esto un once
contra once y siempre gana alemania
bueno yo quiero empezar hablando de
alemania justamente fue un equipo que
tuvo la pelota se acercó continuamente
al área rival sin embargo no logró ser
profundo no logró tener ese último base
enlazar a los delanteros y ahí le costó
yo creo que me gustó mucho la definición
que usó el diario 'el país' que dice que
este equipo por educación y convicción
nunca se rinde y lo vimos hasta el
último minuto que presionó en su campo
incluso a francia pero parece que eso es
lo que quiere
francia quiere hacer sentir al rival que
está en control del partido para luego
darle el golpe siempre va a ser un
placer ver a mbappe con esas
aceleraciones por la banda pero ayer no
brillaron las figuras de francia ayer
brillaron los tres mediocampistas rabia
cante y pogba creo que demostraron que
son jugadores que no sólo trabajan sino
que desequilibran en el área rival y yo
creo que además este france y no sólo se
queda con tres puntos sino que demuestra
que la idea está muy consolidada y esos
muy pocos equipos digamos que tienen esa
fortuna en un torneo como éste ahora
hablabas de alemania se alojó y poco el
partido de hummers pero hizo un muy buen
partido y le tocó bailar con mbappe y
más allá de los desbordes que vimos en
papel comerci se portó a un buen nivel
alemán hizo un buen papel la verdad es
que pero quedó la sensación de que
francia es mejor equipo y que sigue
siendo el favorito para la eurocopa si
alemania tuvo la posesión pero es eso es
una posesión es una es una excesiva de
elaboración del juego que no les permite
hacer daño en el campo rival lo de gmail
es complicado porque después de estar
beta
tras el mundial de 2018 de rusia vuelve
a la selección comete este autogol pero
obviamente a causa de una situación de
juego en el que muchos factores
confluyeron este alemán ya tiene que
trabajar lastimosamente para löw hay muy
poco tiempo pues es su última su último
torneo al frente del equipo y vamos a
ver cómo se van los otros partidos pues
porque portugal ya hablaremos un poco no
la tuvo fácil tampoco así es y vamos a
cerrar este bloque de francia y
alemania- con otro gesto de rueda de
prensa que está dando de hay que hablar
poco va después del partido retiró unas
botellas de cerveza imitando lo que
había hecho antes cristiano ronaldo con
unos refrescos que también patrocinan el
torneo algún comentario eso era a mí me
gusta que los futbolistas opinen o sea
me parece que luego hablaremos de lo
contractual y de lo que esto significa
para la economía y para los temas de
mercado de los torneos pero me gusta que
los futbolistas que siempre son como
también puestos que no expresan sus
opiniones respecto a nada que tengan una
posición me parece que está bien porque
vaya ronaldo nos dicen que veamos agua y
uno de los protagonistas de la jornada
fue precisamente cristiano ronaldo quien
marcó dos goles y se convirtió en el
máximo anotador en la historia
la eurocopa por delante de michel
platini que se quedó con nueve el luso
lidera una lista de ilustres delanteros
que la podemos ver al ángel de rus van
nistelroy entre otros ayer ronaldo marcó
un doblete y ayuda a su equipo a superar
un partido que a pesar de ese 3-0 fue
muy muy complicado contra hungría no
habíamos anticipado aquí y hungría no
iba a darse por vencido fácilmente ayer
le costaron tres cosas fundamentalmente
tres problemas tuvo portugal uno no tuvo
dominio en el medio campo no tuvo
creación ideas en la creación y el
tercero fue el portero peter gulacsi de
hungría que estuvo tuvo una noche
imperial ahora después de que en el
minuto 83 se abre el marcador del
partido aparece este señor cristiano
ronaldo con un doblete el primero de
penal y es eso se convierte no sólo en
el máximo goleador de la eurocopa sino
en el primer jugador que ha disputado
cinco ediciones de este torneo cuando
usted piensa que estaba haciendo en el
2004 en el 2008 en el 2012 en el 2016
bueno pues este señor ha estado
escribiendo la historia del fútbol
mundial así desde 2004 eurocopa que
perdió portugal en esa final contra
vamos a cambiar de tema porque este
miércoles se abre la segunda fecha del
euro euro y tenemos tres partidos en el
grupo b rusia le ganó al finlandia y
consiguió su primer triunfo ahora mismo
en juego por el grupo ha partido entre
turquía y galés minuto 59 victoria
parcial para galés más adelante está y
le recibe en el olímpico de a suiza en
el olímpico de roma estará una rusia que
fue superior a finlandia y superó un
equipo que se defiende muy bien si
finlandia ya habían mostrado en el
partido con dinamarca en el que termina
quedándose con los tres puntos pero
después del incidente de eriksen que
evidentemente cambia absolutamente el
contexto en el que se desarrolló el
juego hoy rusia encontró en un volante
del atalanta del atalanta está poniendo
muchos jugadores interesantes en las
diversas selecciones él logró un buen
resultado vamos a ver en el primer
partido había quedado muy en deuda estos
son los dos equipos que entran a animar
también los grupos así que es un
resultado apenas interesante y pues para
irlo anotando ahí en nuestra tabla de
posiciones
así nos queda pendiente hablar de ese
partido entre tales yo sé que vamos a
tener más adelante y vamos a pasar ya
hablar de la copa américa segundo día de
descanso en la copa américa mañana
jueves regresa la acción con dos
partidos por el grupo b
pero en río de janeiro y colombia se
enfrenta a venezuela en goiánia juegan
mañana los dos equipos que ganaron en su
debut y vamos a empezar hablando de
brasil la vigente de campeona que ya
mostró en su último entrenamiento que se
vieron al parecer algunos cambios
respecto a esa alineación inicial para
ese partido contra perú sí y aunque ya
hemos hablado que no brilló en el
partido con venezuela que tenía un
montón de bajas y te sigue trabajando la
defensa parece que los cambios van a ser
militado y thiago silva es decir un
equipo que siempre lo pensamos en el
ataque esta estructura dándose desde
atrás y tiene muy buenas opciones va a
ser un partido interesante sin duda no
hemos visto a perú un perú que también
en las eliminatorias ha intentado
cambiar de sistema encontrar nuevas
fichas cuenta con la baja de paolo
guerrero que al final no viaja la copa y
que dejar la padula como este titular en
punta para el equipo peruano la paula
que viene de hacer unas muy buenas
eliminatorias a pesar de que su debut no
fue muy bueno con perú se reivindicó en
ese partido contra ecuador desbordando
por la banda yo creo que pero a
diferencia de brasil se iba a tener que
con todo lo que se dice la pesada parece
el primer partido repetición de la final
de la última copa américa sílaba
es que el equipo de ricardo gareca
trabaja los partidos pero no ha logrado
buenos resultados en la eliminatoria
está absolutamente complicado o sea que
para gareca este torneo sí va a ser muy
importante incluso para conseguir
resultados y aquí lo hemos contado en un
grupo que pasan cuatro pues tiene luego
la chance de que en el mata mata incluso
pueda meterse en la final como lo hizo
en la anterior copa américa y vamos a
escuchar que dijo precisamente fred uno
de los integrantes de la selección
brasileña acerca de perú el rival al que
se va a enfrentar mañana todos saben que
no hay partidos fáciles en la copa
américa y el último fue muy complicado a
pesar del hecho de que ellos no tenían a
sus jugadores principales sabemos qué
tan difícil fue en el campo pero
conseguimos hacer un buen trabajo y
ganarlo en contra vale ser victoriosos
colombia por su parte se mide a
venezuela un rival que últimamente le
venía costando y sobre el que hasta hace
muy poco colombia consiguió cambiar a su
favor esa tendencia negativa que venía
de los últimos partidos si lo de
colombia es interesante yo creo que
reinaldo rueda está adaptando nuevas
metodologías de entrenamiento nuevos
conceptos con respecto a lo que venía
el técnico carlos queiróz vamos a ver un
partido un buen partido aquí les cuento
que el equipo aún no ha entrenado su
once titular porque el espacio entre los
partidos es muy reducido y poco tiempo
de trabajo venezuela sigue
obviamente cargando el lastre deportivo
de tener esas 13 bajas para la primera
fecha del torneo y me decían hoy los
colegas venezolanos que es casi una
telenovela venezolana poder intentar
armar ese 11 porque están muy
dependientes de los pcr scada pcr le
indica al técnico jose peseiro con qué
fichas puede contar para este partido
impresionante es una nueva situación a
la que nos hemos visto en esta copa
américa pero yo creo que a pesar de todo
colombia mañana es obviamente parte como
gran favorito y se da el lujo también de
lo que hemos visto de rotar jugadores y
probando para el objetivo definitivo que
parece cierto es a ese mundial de qatar
donde el 22 tenemos que dejar hasta aquí
el programa porque habla el presidente
de eeuu joe biden
después de su encuentro con su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin en esa gira en
ginebra suiza para terminar su cumbre en
europa vamos a escuchar al presidente
eeuu gracias